[Music]
you're touring all over the place you
tour globally too you go different
countries yeah is this true you were i
don't know if you went or you were
planning to go to nigeria did you i mean
that'd be a fascinating experience it
was it was fascinating until they start
playing with my money uh
one of the nigerian dudes like yeah man
i'm gonna bring you over and bring you
and
as the month went on and i'm getting
close to going to the date people was
like so what are you playing next and
i'm like nigeria that's like whoa
be careful when you go over there
cause i'm like man
what if i get over there and then i want
my money and they like you don't have no
money here
they start shooting them little
what
that's not gonna happen
cause that's what they rob people with
them a little they don't have no guns
they just walk up to you and say give me
the money now
now you staying there with your hand
turn around let me shoot you in the
booty
that's just not true
none of that is true
no you do tour a lot you tour a lot here
in the states do you ever people that
tour a lot
sometimes uh forget where they are i did
a tour like two years ago and i swear to
god there were mornings i'd wake up and
i think i'd have to think for a second
what city is where are you at man you
you gotta really bro he do it you roll
over sometime and look you gotta look at
the phone to see what city you're in
right and then i deal with a lot of
janky promoters you know the last show i
did a guy paid me in all five dollar
bills
is that true yeah true story all five
dollar bills all five dollar bills he
had just got through selling the nickel
bags
so i had to help him earn out all the
five dollar bills
[Laughter]
you uh you started your comedy career is
that right in new york city oh yeah
where were you coming from when you went
to new york city i'm from indianapolis
you know um home of the 2012 super bowl
we just had the super bowl yes i'm aware
of that congratulations yeah and uh i
moved to new york city because you know
what nothing but i i think i went on
stage maybe once a year out there
because they only had one comedy club
that was open one time out of the year
and your buddy dion that works on the
uncle yeah yeah he used to come to the
comedy club that's right that's where
everyone would gather and he owed me 40
dollars from back then i'm just now
getting my money yeah are you getting it
back tonight i can't be out here with
them little tight shorts on
you get that 40 back i don't want it out
of them shorts
uh now next saturday uh uh you are
performing at the theater at madison
square garden oh yeah and uh for msg i i
thought i'd never go to madison square
garden this is huge i started out
performing in bar and grills yeah
yeah and now madison square garden now
madison square guard man i can't believe
you're doing two shows i'm doing two
shows all right i think i'm doing two
shows i want to do two
i think oh yeah i don't know
yeah
yeah i'm doing two shows yeah yeah i
think i'm doing two so it'd be great if
you went the second night you're not but
just because i said it you just went out
there the second night yeah and carrot
top's performing you know he's
your cousin i was just cute
[Applause]
i didn't say that i didn't say that
hey now second cousin your second cousin
i i could have said donald trump
[Applause]